so today we're gonna talk about receding
hairline what to do about it okay like
one day you're like what you're looking
at me or going what is happening to my
hair I'm losing my hair two reasons one
is that you have higher levels of
something called 5-alpha reductase this
is an enzyme this enzyme converts
testosterone into a more powerful form
of testosterone called DHT and this can
definitely burn out the hair follicles
and also on top as well
okay second reason is higher antigens
that aren't necessarily caused by this
increase in this enzyme but your
antigens are just higher okay antigens
are male hormones but females have
antigens but not in the quantities that
males have if a female has to much
antigen she's going to get facial hair
acne because of the enlargement of the
sebaceous gland or the oil gland and
large learnings what's that going to do
it's gonna drop the voice a deeper voice
axillary hairs armpit hair and a female
this is called polycystic ovarian
syndrome or disorder okay so how do we
reduce 5 alpha reductase this enzyme
what you do is you take a natural 5
alpha reductase inhibitor zinc is at the
top of the list and if you think about
it zinc is also really important in your
immune system okay so if you have
alopecia for example which is an
autoimmune condition this would be very
very important in which case you would
want to also add vitamin D and law in
large quantities okay number two omega-3
fatty acids number three vitamin b2 all
three of these can inhibit this enzyme
and lessen the amount of DHT being
produced all right next one antigens how
do we normalize antigens in a female as
in how do we improve polycystic ovarian
syndrome well guess what the one of the
biggest causes to this is high levels of
insulin okay high levels of insulin
which cause insulin resistance end up
causing too many energy
so you guessed it get on keto and in a
minute fasting but these two actions
will help greatly normalize insulin
which will then help normalize androgens
and if you're a guy and you have too
much antigen especially in the form of
DHT okay do these right here as well as
these right here all right see you next
video so if you want to get notified
with all my content click the
notification bell next to subscribed